this is peter rubin flying solo this
time for a very special episode of game
life I'm here on Microsoft campus we've
got an exclusive look at something you
might have heard a little some about but
we're the only ones with the details so
let's take a look why do I look like a
clay man right now here to answer that
question please introduce yourself sir
yeah I'm Scott Evans I'm the group
program manager for connect at Microsoft
excellent so Scott this is what this is
just a 3d depth map of the new Kinect
sensor correct yeah you're seeing what
the sensor itself sees you're seeing
yourself represented here in three
dimensions the 3d vision itself which is
what made connects famous we've made
high definition and high fidelity
if you step a little closer even you can
see the buttons in your shirt these
buttons you can see then this is little
my new changes in depth that we can see
with the sensor now Kinect is more than
just a 3d vision camera it also has a 2d
vision camera and you can see that we've
got a 1080p High Definition color feed
across that whole field of view but one
of the challenges with a color feed is
it's very susceptible to changes in room
lighting so we've introduced a new
technology we call active IR yeah and
the magic here is really in how it
filters out room lighting and a good way
to show that is we can make we can lower
the lights in this room we can close the
blinds and you'll see that that color
image becomes unusable but this active
IR image is completely unchanged I can't
see any differences from when it was
light in the room and when it was
totally dark in the room and another fun
way to show this technology or will use
this little flashlight here and you can
simulate a lamp for example on the side
and we'll go back to color and you can
imagine if the lamp was sitting next to
you on the end table right completely
washing out only half of your face and
if we go back to active IR we can see
that that light is completely removed
from the scene let's bring the lights
back up ok yeah so all of this we I
should just point out this is just all
what the the Kinect sensor sees and
hears before it gets worked into an
experience for you at home with the Xbox
exactly now the first capability of
skeletal tracking ok this was one of the
cortex that we introduced with Kinect
for 3 6 9 and you see that we've taken
skeletal tracking and mate and leverage
that 3d vision and made it
high-definition as well we've got more
joints more aggressive movement you can
see the lean in your spine you can shrug
your shoulders all that movement
being represented here in your skeleton
we even have enough fidelity to show
your your your hand joints the Tokyo
fingers your sums we can have out of
inches egg on it knows if I'm pointing a
gun at the screen yep what if I want to
go menace to society and go from the
side got it got it your style okay
now on top of skeletal tracking we have
enough fidelity to even look at how your
joints are rotating I'm going to turn on
rotation and this is a representation we
call boxman no more cheating and dance
central it is going to know exactly what
you're doing weave in your head if you
rotate your head and make little circles
there we can see that represented as
well so we can see exactly where you're
looking in the room my yoga game is
going to be on point we can combine a
physics model on start to understand
muscles and forces that are exerted
through the body we're going to turn
that on here we've got a representation
here of you and what you're seeing is as
the skeletons moving from green to red
it's showing where the force is being
applied okay you're shifting your weight
and you're saying the weight shift on
one foot
if you jump up in the air while you're
midair you'll be all green because
they're gonna force and as you land you
see your feet turn red and we can even
see force applied through movement so if
you throw some punches here at the
sensor we see these white circles if you
put your back into it however we can see
a much bigger circle yet but how about a
fireball oh ah it's on now
Street Fighter we're coming on top of
muscle and force from a fitness
perspective we can also start to
estimate your heart rate so we're gonna
bring that up we use the sensor feed
okay we can look for patches of your
skin and look at micro fluctuations in
the blood underneath your skin and
estimate your heart rate from that and
then finally we start to look at the
people nerman estimate moods and how
they're feeling and how they're engaging
with the system through what we call our
expressions platform we'll bring that up
and here you can see that we doomed in
your face and we can show if you're
neutral or smiling we can see if you're
looking at the system versus looking
away maybe you're reading a newspaper
playing with your smartphone now did you
actually use me as a reference for this
expression guy because that is that's
uncanny it is a very close resemblance
that's our generic representation of
what's going on so I'm going to jump in
the scene with you I'm going to grab it
troller okay now we've got two people
now your control and I'm controller one
your controller two I can we can change
controllers but then it'll and you can
see that it knows now that we've swapped
controller and it's signed you in its
signed to me in automatically use it
because I've used this this Xbox before
you didn't have to do the whole thing
where you wave and then it sees you and
you have to sign in to do it just
recognized me and sign me and we can
even switch positions here and you can
see that not only did the controllers
follow us but we swap spaces on the
screen so you can imagine a multiplayer
game now it doesn't matter where I'm
sitting in the couch I can jump in
without any user interface without any
sign in and the screen can split
relative to where I'm sitting in the
room we've got orientation we've got
Muslim force we've got heart rate we've
got expression engagement we've got dark
but what if we tie this all together and
do five people in the door we can do six
but we could we'll do five here okay
good a minute alright we'll slow it down
for you then I'll bring up skeletal
tracking again let's bring some friends
in yeah let's cut the lights all right
totally dark totally dark all right guys
come on in I'll switch over to active IR
so we can see in the dark here get bring
in more panel in here see now look at
that let's jump one two three all right
Simon Says touch your head crane
technique oh you have to do the Harlem
shake
at-at-at knob display all right you got
it wired
you